so meine Damen und Herren
äh nun
aber zur Überraschung der Woche robert
habbeck ist wieder da im Frühjahr wir
erinnern uns noch politisch quasi
erledigt nach dem ganzen heizungsdebakel
startet er jetzt wieder durch was für
ein Comeback der Wahnsinn
ja zum einen gibt's völlig zurecht viel
Lob für sein großartiges videostatement
zum Thema Antisemitismus zum anderen
will dieser Mann die deutsche Wirtschaft
retten leider bitter nötig 2023 fällt
das erhoffte leichte Wachstum aus
stattdessen schrumpfen wir um 0,4% als
einzige Industrienation weltweit
Deutschland ist so am Boden wir können
uns nicht mal mehr eine anständige
PowerPoint Präsentation leisten hier das
ist der Trichter von Corona dann haben
wir uns rausgekämpft raus rausgearbeitet
aus diesem wirtschaftlichen Einbruch und
dann hier der Rückgang der der
wirtschaftlichen Leistung um 0,4% hier
das ist die Bodenbildung die Talbildung
und dann soll es jetzt eigentlich wieder
anziehen ja soll eigentlich müsste
hoffentlich vielleicht nächstes Jahr im
Moment ganz aktuell heißt es noch willst
du Deutschland oben sehen musst du die
Tabelle drehen ja gut aber jetzt kommt
ja vielleicht die Wende Freunde mit
habbexs industriestrategie und da steht
zumindest einiges drin was
wahrscheinlich die ganze Ampel
unterschreiben kann Maßnahmen gegen
Fachkräftemangel für mehr
Digitalisierung bessere Infrastruktur
weniger marode Brücken solche Sachen ja
kann keiner was dagegen haben
vorgestellt hat der habbeck das Ganze
übrigens im eigen gebuchten Berliner
Radialsystem das ist voll die coole
Eventlocation extra grün angeleuchtet es
gab eine ganz harte Tür Anton Hofreiter
als Bouncer als Vorband Spiel ein
Scooter how much ist der
industriestrompreis und dann das
Highlight Robert kommt zu KL von
mit dem düsenrucksack auf die Bühne
geflogen geil ja fette Veranstaltung
diese Location ist so hip Gert Schröder
will die schon für seine nächste
Hochzeit buchen ja aber zurück zur
Eingangsfrage von Scooter how much ist
industriestrompreis bzw kommt
industriestrompreis überhaupt also der
deutlich verbilligte Strompreis für
energieintensive Branchen weiß ich nicht
denn leider kann sich die Regierung in
dieser entscheidenden Frage nach
monatenstreit immer noch nicht einigen
gegen die Subvention spricht z.B der
Mittelstand hätte kaum was davon und ob
die EU zustimmen würde weiß auch noch
keiner auf der anderen Seite könnten
bestimmte Industrien sonst ins Ausland
abwandern und es ist schlicht unfassbar
dass der Kanzler sich bei dem Thema
völlig raushält und den Streit einfach
nur laufen lässt ja einfach nur laufen
lässt schon wieder und schon wieder
heißt es also habbeck gegen Lindner denn
sie anes industriestrompreis geht nicht
Zusam mit Schuldenbremse sie wissen ja
die ist Christians persönlicher Fetisch
nach dem Motto Christian Spar D richtig
hart durch
ja
so die Alternative zur Subvention z.B
eine bessere Infrastruktur für alle
Betriebe für alle geht ja auch nicht mit
Schuldenbremse können wir über die nicht
wenigstens noch mal reden ja natürlich
wenn wir gezwungen werden würden die
Schuldenbremse auszusetzen oder die
Steuern zu erhöhen dann würde sich die
Koalitionsfrage stellen aber niemand tut
das doch hier ich tue das ich tue das ja
und nicht nur ich das Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft fordert öffentliche
Investition von der Schuldenbremse
auszunehmen Christian das hier ist eine
Intervention wo ist meine Lindner
interventionscam ach da vorne Christian
du hältst die Schuldenbremse gar nicht
ein du arbeitest mit Schattenhaushalten
das ist exakt dasselbe wie Schulden du
willst nur das Wort Schulden nicht sagen
aus Trotz oder Ideologie keine Ahnung
mittlerweile t so als wä die
Schuldenbremse ein ein lebendiges Wesen
dass du beschützen musst unsere
Schuldenbremse ist intelligent sie nimt
die konjunkturelle Entwicklung wahr oh
Gott unsere Schuldenbremse ist
intelligent geworden wir müssen sie
töten bevor sie Eier
legt die Transformation der deutschen
Wirtschaft geht nicht ohne große
Investition und wenn du das als
Finanzminister nicht kapierst dann
müsstest du ein ehrliches
Personalgespräch mit dir selber führen
und dir sagen dein Arbeitsplatz fällt
weg geh nach Hause wir brauchen dich
nicht mehr ja hart aber warahr meine
Damen und Herren ja die Ampel bremst
nicht nur bei Schulden sie bremst sich
so selber aus das ist total schade
wirklich denn unsere Wirtschaft chtzt ja
tatsächlich unter den hohen Strompreisen
die deutschen Firmen zahlen dreimal so
viel wie ihre Konkurrenz in den USA als
Beispiel das ist ein riesen Problem in
einem Land mit viel Industrie und
Exportlastigkeit um uns als ehemalige
russengasjunkys wirklich unabhängig zu
machen müssen vor allem die Erneuerbaren
noch viel viel schneller ausgebaut
werden auch da macht die Ampel längst
nicht genug Druck Föderalismus hin oder
her es reicht nicht wir sprachen schon
drüber immer nur zu wiederholen was man
machen müsste wir brauchen fünf bis
sechs Windkraftanlagen an Land pro Tag
vier bis fünf Windräder vier bis fün
Windräder so um die F F bis se pro Tag
täglich vier bis F F bis se mehr als 5 4
bis 5 vi bis 5 pro
Tag ja es ist echt schade dass man diese
Windräder nicht mit der heißen Luft
betreiben kann die Scholz so raushaut
letztes Jahr haben wir unter der Ampel
an Land genau 1,5 Windräder pro Tag
gebaut nicht fünf plus natürlich das
Problem mit der Versorgungssicherheit
Stichwort dunkelflauten also Tage ohne
genug Sonne und Wind genau dafür müssen
sehr sehr viele neue und steuerbare Gas
und Wasserstoff Kraftwerke rechtzeitig
fertig werden riskante Wette würde ich
sagen in diesem Sinne herzlich
Willkommen
[Musik]
zu hallo
wöblingen servus grüß Gott m ist das
eine hässliche
Stadthalle so
kinderomas lässt sich entschuldigen sein
höhgerät ist kaputt topwette heute Abend
und zwar von ruert aus Schleswig
Holstein vollknuffiger Minister in
seiner Freizeit reißt er gerne anderen
Leuten die Heizung
raus der ruert möchte Versorgungslücken
beim Strom verhindern so dafür muss er
aber und das ist seine Wette das Tempo
beim Ausbau der Erneuerbaren mehr als
verdreifachen und alle neuen Backup
Kraftwerke pünktlich fertigstellen
Rat ganz schön große Schnauze wie siehst
du denn selber so die Chancen ich
bestätige meine Prognose
5050 jao fi50y immer noch besser als
halber
halber 48 neue Kraftwerke müssen gebaut
werden darunter reine
wasserstoffkraftwerke für die es aber
noch gar keine Ausschreibung gibt obwohl
die ersten schon in 5 Jahren ans Netz
gehen sollen was sagt man dazu können
wir das schaffen wir schaffen das Nein
in absolut gar keinem Fall schaffen wir
das aber selbst wenn sagen jetzt
Experten könnte es 2030 bei
dunkelflauten eine Stromlücke von bis zu
3 Terawattstunden geben blöd wobei
Robert
2030 bist du dann überhaupt noch
Minister also da würde ich jetzt ungerne
spekulieren ja würde ich auch ungne an
deiner Stelle sagen wir mal so sehr
wahrscheinlich sitzt du dann schon auf
hallich Hoge und schreibst Gedichte über
Ponys mir egal ich habe all mein Geld
längst in Kerzen investiert schön blöd
wer das nicht gemacht hat Kerzen werden
bald die Währung wie Kaffee nach dem
Krieg so jetzt Licht aus das ZF muss
Strom sparen Wetter verloren
tschüss so
Aufnahme hallo dies ist die automatische
endcart von Oliver Welke und der heute
show leider ist das Video schon vorbei
ihr könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen